I'm saying that looking at all of the
evidence the best contender for an
explanation currently is a thing called
a whales catfish
it doesn't mean that tomorrow if a four
foot long neck sticks up out of the lock
behind me here it doesn't mean I'm not
going to photograph it because it
doesn't fit with the picture of a wels
catfish at the moment that's my best
guess
as to the answer it's still the world's
greatest mystery as I speak
but given that you've spent 25 years
looking for it given that we've had all
sorts of pinger devices going up and
down that lock looking for Nessie no
sign whatsoever is it time to give up
and say that actually there isn't a lot
nicer monster well I don't know where
you are but if you sit here then you
wouldn't be able to say no sign
whatsoever because we have a steady
trickle of information okay and lately
in the last few years we only get one or
two decent sightings a year but we get
sonar contacts with things that are just
far bigger than any fish that should
live in this body of water we get there
you've got so much evidence to put into
one jigsaw puzzle but still we haven't
got the overall picture all I'm
currently saying is that looking at all
the evidence talking to all the
eyewitnesses the most common the most
likely solution is a thing called whales
catfish I'm not saying that's the answer
I'm not saying I'm not saying the
mystery sold for a minute and I'm not
saying I'm about to stop I'm still
looking for a better explanation than
that maybe it's a Russian submarine well
I think if we had a Russian submarine in
Loch Ness then that would be a
world-class incident in history in
itself so if I end up photograph in that
then so be it
if we can't find a monster we wouldn't
be able to find a submarine would we
yeah yeah I suppose you're right yeah I
don't know it would have to come in by
Road they wouldn't it so I think we'd
see it coming through the centre of
Inverness yeah you've got a point
suppose the same with the monster but
maybe not I mean 25 years on the edge of
the Loch looking
for the Loch Ness monster not found him
giving up your home giving up your job
giving up your girlfriend was it all
worth it
it's I'm absolutely and utterly in my
utopia living here on the shores of the
Loch trying to solve what I say is one
of the world's greatest mysteries and
the more that an individual looks at the
evidence the more you realize we do have
something to be explained here we people
are seeing something bigger than our
biggest animals that we get in the water
here that we know of
salmon okay salmon or seals that
occasionally come in chasing those
salmon and these things are the size of
an estate car that we're getting sonar
contacts with so I'm here to identify
that I'm quite happy doing that as well
Steve 25 years we've been doing it Sky
News has been on the air longer than 25
years and the joke used to be in the
early days that more people had seen the
Loch Ness monster than had seen Sky News
now something like 130 million people
see Sky News and still nobody's seen the
Loch Ness monster how many people go to
church every Sunday we've got
photographs of Nessie we've got sonar
contacts we've got eyewitness accounts
we've got more evidence than there is
for God you know you're not comparing
Nessie to God though are you I'm not
comparing it's not the same thing this
is this is an explainable phenomena okay
but you're going to carry on oh yeah I'm
here for the next decade yeah unless I
go and solve it if tomorrow I get the
conclusive proof of whatever's in here
then that's me I have to go off and
solve another lakes monster
international monster hunter that's my
next career once I solve this one well
good luck to you maybe she just appears
when you've gone to sleep or something I
don't know well I've covered that
possibility occasionally so yeah we've
still not solved it yet but the mystery
still remains there is something to be
explained in Loch Ness absolutely maybe
your chat to us if you do find her or
him don't know which one it is but it's
great to talk to you Steve thanks so
much indeed for joining us thank you